في رساله مهمه وفيديو مؤثر كشفت
الاعلاميه راندا كراتشا عن اصعب تجربه في
حياتها قالت لي متابعيها انها حرمت من ان
تكون اما بعد استئصال رحمها مبينه انها
اكتشف ذلك في الرابع عشر من شهر ديسمبر
لفتت الى ان صعوبه الانجاب دفعتها الى
فكره تجميد البويضات لكنها عند اللجوء الى
الطبيبه لهذا الغرض اكتشفت ان لديها ورمين
مقدمه نصيحتها بفحص الرحم والمبايض بشكل
خاص لانها طريقه الوحيده لمعرفه الاصابه
بالاورام
14/12/2022 او اليوم اللي عرفت هي بحياتي
ما راح تصير ام
اسمي رنده وعمري 37 سنه
من لحظه اكتشاف في الاورام لغايه هذا
اليوم هي تجربه مؤلمه ما زالت مؤلمه بكل
تفاصيلها الالم موجود
والحال لن يتغير لكن اللي بيتغير هو
تقبل الموضوع وجدت نفسي كما تفضلت امام
مفترق طرق يا اما انطوي على نفسي واسكر
على الموضوع واعيش هذا الالم لوحدي او اني
اشارك الجميع
بهذه التجربه
ونشر الوعي والامل في هذا الشان
صورت الفيديو وصدقا حضرت الفيديو ولم
اتقبل رؤيه نفسي بهذا الوجع وهذا الالم
تركته حكيت انا ما راح انشر هذا الفيديو
شعور داخلي بقى كل يوم اصحى واحس انه لا
في مسؤوليه اكبر وهذا الفيديو يجب ان
ينتشر وصوتي لازم يطلع
لحد ما اخذت القرار انه خلص انا راح انشر
الفيديو
واكتشف انه الثامن من ايار هو اليوم
العالمي اللي سرطان المبايض
نشرت الفيديو هو وجود اليوم هو ليس بسبب
نشري لهذا الفيديو هو بسبب
متابعين كثر حول العالم قرروا ان يضموا
صوتهم لصوتي لنشر هذه الرساله رساله مهمه
جدا
زي ما حكى عادل يعني كلك شجاعه للحديث
والخوض في هذا الموضوع ومحاوله انك تفيدي
غيرك من هذه التجربه رغم المها الكبير
رنده خلينا نركز على موضوع يعني رسالتك
انت من خلال هذا الفيديو ومن خلال هذه
التجربه صدقا راويه يمكن هذا الشيء اللي
انا شعرته ولمسته من خلال المتابعين ومن
خلال مشاركه التجارب الشخصيه اللي هم عم
بيمروا فيها ربما يمكن احنا بنعرف انه
سرطان الثدي او السرطان عمق الرحم بلشنا
نسمع شوي عن
الوعي اكثر في في هذا الشان لكن بالتحديد
سرطان المبيض ما يعني في ناس بقولوا لي
احنا ما كنا عارفين انه الثامن من ايار له
يوم هذا النوع من السرطانات لغايه الان في
ناس عم بيبعثوا لي ليش شلتي رح ليش شلت
الموبايل وكل هذا الموضوع يمكن من خلالكم
اليوم ومن خلال
هذا الشيء صار موضوع وعي بالفحص المبكر
موضوع مهم جدا احنا اليوم رسالتنا اكبر
ليس فقط في الاردن لكن لنشرها في العالم
العربي والعالم اجمع
[موسيقى]